All right.
So I'm professor David Lummis and a
professor Mazzotta asked me to come in and
substitute for him today since
he's traveling and can't be here.
So I guess we'll get started and I
just wanted to write since there was a
midterm last time and remind
you more or less of what
he was talking about
whenever you left off. Um,
okay.
The last lecture I suppose was about
the relationship between spacious and
Virgil,
the specifically poetic relationship and
the ambiguity that arises in the father
son relationship,
that stage between stations and virtual.
So Stacy has recognizes the Centralia
virtual for his own poetic career and his
own moral development
by saying through you,
I was a poet and through you I was
a Christian, but at the same time,
um,
his poetry challenges that have a virtual
professional mounts up that concluded,
you know, stating that,
um, stages, stages.
His poem is about a tragedy about
the tragedy of birth. All right.
While Virgil's is about the,
um,
the history making quality
of the event of birth,
that this would be,
it challenged Virgil's account of,
of the foundation of the foundation.
And of history,
but he grew as a poet and converted to
Christianity by engaging with virtual
zone ideas of history,
specifically with the uh,
fourth log.
And there there's a misreading.
So the generative quality of,
of Virgil's poetry did it,
was it intrinsic in the poetry itself,
but was based on stations to this
particular reading of the text.
Um,
and today we're going to be talking
about condos 24 and 26 specifically,
but I'll be saying a few words also
about is 23 and 25 as a kind of frame to
those two con d.
Um,
and in these two condo is 24 and 26.
Um, they can tease
Canthi, continue the, um,
the meditation on political
relationships that
were going on in 21 and 22 with stations.
Now the restaurant mounts out
there in his book, the Dante,
the poet of the desert,
has pointed out that Dante utilizes the,
figured out a method of reading history,
uh,
whereby the past prefigures
the president in the future
in a poetic fashion in
order to understand, um,
the genealogy of poetry of poets and in
order to place himself in a typological
genealogy of poets.
Um,
and then these Conti Dante
is engaged in a kind of,
in a sustained reflection,
not sought,
that says on literary history and the
powers of literature to engender moral
conversion and in probing the
inevitable limits of poetic fictions.
And there I quoted from his book,
um, Dante poet of the desert
now since 24,
which you read for today,
follows directly on [inaudible] 23
with a conversation between photos,
it Donati and the pilgrim.
I want to say a few words about 23.
Um, especially regarding the relationship
between, between poetry and gluttony.
Okay.
And although a number of Penitence are
mentioned at the beginning of this Condo,
Dante only speaks to two of them.
Four days.
It doe not the born on June to that Luca.
And both of them are poets.
And the first one is specifically
a friend of Dante. Okay.
Um, now for is it or not?
They do not for [inaudible].
Donati was and in Dante
is youth. Um, like I said,
a friend and they exchanged a series
of recuperative sonnets in which they
insulted each other back and
forth. And it was filled with, um,
with language of bodily sensation.
And um,
uh,
I suppose in this Condo,
the language of the conversation
between four days there and the pilgrim,
um,
sheds a new light.
The memory of it causes a bitterness
in both full days and in the pilgrim.
And the difference between
the rhetoric of the two texts,
uh, Mark's a new moral
vision in the pilgrim. Okay.
So blood before in these,
in these sonnets,
they berated each other's wives and um,
and their, their vices and this
condo, they recognize each other,
they treat each other like
brothers. So it's really a, um,
[inaudible] formation of a
poetic community that was
in some sense distorted by
these two songs. Maybe these analogies.
Six A son. It's three for each poet,
um, in, in the, in this Condo,
the glutinous are finished and disfigured
by hunger and their pin hints right?
And do not,
these wife wears it on.
His wife is recalled and she was treated
with obscenity in the sonnets and she's
remembered as it's steel
and vista kind of woman, um,
whose prayers ironically have helped
four days.
It arrive at the terrorist so
quickly. Right? So in a, in a way,
it really converts that kind of letting
this bodily poetry into a different kind
of moralized moralizing
poetry, I suppose. All right.
It corrects it.
Now I guess the connection,
another connection with gluttony is that,
what is it along with a number of other
Italian poets such as Jak one jeweled
Yeti,
um,
it was probably the most famous was a
burlesque poet and this is also known as
Goldie odic poetry.
So from Gulag Latin for
wrote or for gluttony.
Um,
and so this oblique connection allows
Dante to speak about poetry in this condo
of gluttony.
All right.
Is the real connection is
that it's a world, the whites,
they're worldly type of poetry that
doesn't look beyond itself beyond the
concerns of the flesh, I
suppose. All right. Um,
I would like to point out at
the end of this console, um,
Dante remembers their ribald
literary exchange with,
with bitterness at lines
one 15 at the very end.
Um, he connects the, the period
of his friendship with the Nazi,
with a dilemma back in the dark
forest and come to one. Okay.
Um,
let's see if we got the right place.
If that bring back to mind without ha
without west with me and I with the,
the president memory will
be grievous still. So yeah,
he's pointing out that he has a different
perspective on that time of his life.
Okay.
He,
that goes before me turned me from that
life some days ago when the sister of
him and I pointed to the son,
showed herself around to you.
It is,
he that has led me through the profound
night of the truly dead with this true
flesh that follows him.
His suckers have drawn me up,
events, climbing and circling the
mountain, which straightens you,
whom the world made crooked.
So
the motor,
I guess if it's of his,
of this change that Dante experiences
are both virtual and Beatrice.
So he's pointing towards
what's making him, what's,
what makes him different from
what he was a few days ago. So,
and they actually,
the exchange with four days,
there was probably not that long before
the composition of the divine comedy.
Okay. Or at least not that long
before the, um, the fictional date of,
of the divine comedy.
Um,
and this,
in reality,
I guess it was a prelude to how he
dramatizes the differences between the,
his poetry and that of
his fathers and brothers,
the ones that he meets in 24 and 26.
Okay.
That's just as a preface I suppose
to what happens in 24 were junk.
They really just juxtaposes
his own style of poetry.
Would that of his predecessors
specifically embodied by
born on June 3rd, I Luca.
And it's interesting that the
June who notices that Dante,
um, is different, right?
Because when I drink that Luca wrote
a poem to we know we need to leave,
we will meet in 26 criticizing how
he had brought the terminology of the
university and the terminology
of epistemology and
metaphysics and theology into
the lyric of love. Okay. So it's,
that's probably one of the reasons
why boardrooms that comes out here,
not necessarily that he was important
for some specific reason to Dante,
but probably because of that the fact
that he, he came out and notice this,
um, in public of weeding
suddenly, okay. This change.
Hmm.
So I'd like to have a look at in the text
when born on June comes
out and addresses Dante.
Okay.
He says in versus 49 through 51.
Um,
but tell me if I see,
hear him that brought forth the new
rhymes beginning with ladies that have
intelligence
love.
So it's born on June two who,
who recognizes Dante and specifically
by the first line in Kip it to the point
that that basically makes
the center of the VTN.
Moreover the turning point and they'd be
tenable. Eventual. Remember [inaudible].
MMM.
And cause in this,
in this poem,
it really marks the transition from
a self centered poetry of love,
where the poet praises himself
obliquely by service to the woman,
to the lady who he loves,
and his transition to a poetry of
praise that is mingled with metaphysical
claims for the ladies to value.
So it's,
it's Dante is transition from
a courtly lyric to a more
philosophical lyric.
Okay.
Now Dante responds to two going on
Juanita with a really beautiful,
beautiful phrase, and he
says, and I said to him,
I am one who when loves, love,
breathes in me, take note,
and in that manner, which he dictates
within, go on to set it forth.
Okay, so this Dante is
claiming his novelty, right?
Um,
and at the same time he's saying he's
linking his own writing of poetry to the
activity of a scribe. Write. He says,
I take note twin someone out when,
when love dictates. Right? So He's,
he's explaining his inspiration
right in the Italian,
um, the word for breathe
in his speeder. Okay.
And he takes, he dictates
within Dante. Okay.
Now
this inspiration, I think it
should, it needs to be understood.
It needs to be understood
in a theological man.
It needs to be understood theologically.
And as we'll go on,
I'm gonna go on to talk
about condo 25 and this,
which explains this
retrospectively, um, in a moment.
But let me just say for now that it,
that the words noto and like
take notes and Italian and,
um,
deep data to dictate an Italian,
um, point towards, uh,
the, um, the inspiration as this
breathing in as the Holy Spirit.
Okay.
As a movement of love within the Trinity.
And that Dante is explaining how,
um,
how poetic inspiration is really a
parallel to the unity of the trinity.
Okay. Um, this inspiration
comes from within.
Um, but it's like someone who
dictates from without. Okay.
Now in the monarch, and then
we're not ikea. And Dante is, um,
political treatise on empire.
He describes God as the only dicks dot.
Or the only person who dictates.
Okay. So we have to understand this,
um, description of poetic
inspiration as one coming from,
um,
and internal instantiation of the divine.
Okay.
So there's a connection between this
inspiration and the divine. Okay.
Um,
now one on junto follows up on this by
professing to understand the not right,
the not that kept him, um, and his
like the, we tone it down, right?
So Jack or Medallian teeny
who is the notary, um,
from arriving at that style at the
tourist that begins at line 55,
he says, oh brother, he said,
now I see the not that held me,
held back the notary and we tone it and
me short of the sweet new style that I
hear,
I see.
Well how you were pins followed
close behind the dictator,
which is surely did not happen with ours.
And he that sets himself to examine
further sees nothing else between the one
style and the other.
And as if satisfied he went,
he was silent.
So we're not doing the things he has
this perspective that purgatory gives him
on his past life and he
understands that not.
And then the no though is also describe
use to describe the sin of gluttony.
And at the beginning of Canto 23.
So here again,
we have this lack of moral understanding.
It's like a moral
perspective in life being,
um, paid for in the
afterlife in purgatory. Um,
okay. Um, but then
so the poetry that Bono winter represents,
um,
it was the one that concentrated
on worldly beauties and qualities.
Like I said before,
it feigned a service to the lady only to
concentrate on the self of the poet and
it never really went beyond,
um, wouldn't beyond itself.
It was a self reflexive kind of poetry.
Um,
and in that sense I guess it could
be assimilated with gluttony. Um,
and I absorbed an imitative,
what came with from without,
without offering fourth,
anything without being generous, such
as the poetry of Virgil was in it. Um,
it's interesting, interesting enough. Um,
but not Giunta says him
that brought forth the new,
the new rhymes. So he brought the new
rhymes. Fourth, he offered them out. Okay.
So one on June is able to
see the difference between
the two styles of poetry at
this point. But I think
he doesn't recognize, um,
the kind of uniqueness that Dante is,
is claiming for himself here because he,
he says,
um, that your pins follow
close behind the dictator.
Right? So he's pluralizing what
Dante says only about himself.
He says in Italian II me
sewing the wound care. Okay.
And people have pointed out that this,
um,
I am one who is both humble and
that it's like I'm one of other,
among others who do this,
but it's also a, um,
it's also pointing out it's
his uniqueness. Others have
pointed out that it, um,
it echoes line three 14 of Exodus Eggo.
Um, some queen soon. There's
what God says to Moses,
I am who I am.
Who Am okay at this self reflexive
[inaudible] me sewing the wound care is an
expression of uniqueness. Okay.
Couched in humble language. Okay.
So Dante is really pointing
out that he is, he is
doing something unique with his poetry,
um,
that perhaps Bono junto doesn't really
recognize the full extent. Okay.
So if there is a school of the
dogist steel normal, right?
If there's this sweet new style,
who composes the school right?
Like the Sicilian school
that proceeded it,
which I'm sure Professor Maths
Sophia talked about in relation to,
they'd be tenable Alpha.
Um,
then Dante is creating something new
within that school. Okay. That's,
I think what's going on here
in those lines. Um, okay.
All right. Um, so I suppose what,
what Dante is doing in this condo is
marking a extreme contrast between his own
poetry and that of the people
who came before him. Okay. Um,
there is a line that divides
these two schools. You know,
the [inaudible] who was a Tuscan
poet who imitated Sicilian poetry.
This is [inaudible] who
imitated a problem, sell poetry.
He's detaching himself from them because
of their lack of immoral purpose,
I suppose, in their poetry. Which one I
drink that recognizes retrospectively.
All right. Now I wanna just
wanted to point out as the, um,
this sort of, as this comes, as
this conversation comes to an end,
Dante describes that,
um,
the [inaudible] 64 through 69,
how the penitents depart,
he says as birds that
winter along the Nile,
sometimes Nica troop in the air,
then fly with more speed and go and file.
So all the people that were there
facing round quicken their steps,
being light with both leanness and desire.
Okay.
And as one tired with the running,
let's his companions go on and then
walks till the heaving of his justice.
So relieved,
so foot as it let the holy flock
pass and come on with me behind.
Okay. So I just wanted to
point out the contrast here.
The image of birds probably reminds
us of the image of birds in Condo.
Five of the inferno,
right? With, they're just,
the sinners were described as cranes who
were being buffeted about by a tempest,
right? And they kept returning
to the same spot in a circle,
like an internal return. Okay. Um, here,
the same kinds of birds,
right? This leads love.
Poets are coming together in a
troop and moving along together.
And not only are they moving
along together, they're
moving forward. All right?
So there's a progress.
That's a count that opposes
the circularity of the,
of the storm of birds in,
in federal five.
And this will come up
again also in Canto 26. Um,
now I know we didn't, didn't read it for
today, um, council of 25 of purgatory,
but I think it shed some light.
I'm going to say a few words about it
because I think it sheds some light on
what Dante was talking about in
relation to inspiration. Okay.
We talked about that
earlier. Um, now what,
what happens here is Dante ass Dunkin's
perplexed about how the centers can be
punished with their bodies if they don't
have bodies. So he asks this of status,
right? So th the whole Condo,
basically he has this of, of a virtual,
I guess in Virgil says it's better
stages, explains it to you. Okay. And,
um, so the pretext of it
all is how can this happen?
What is the physics of what does the
biology of the soul basically in the
afterlife,
but what stations does in
explaining this explains
how God and genders the saw, how
he, how he creates. So, okay.
Um,
now is it placing this discourse
of the generation of the,
of the soul and the body between two
condos that are basically all about poetic
inspiration? Dante think is
drawing a parallel between, um,
divine inspiration and divine creation
and poetic generation and poetic creation.
Okay. Um, okay.
He's been using it as a parent.
He's making a parallel between, um,
poetic generation
inspiration from, um, input,
inspiration and the divine
creation of the, of the soul,
the inspiration of the divine
in the creation of this.
So I'm going to go on and explain what
I mean. I'm just wanting to get that.
Does that make sense? Okay. All right. Um,
I'll slow down a second.
Um,
all right.
So basically he's staging here,
um,
the relationship between the
predecessors and new poets,
so himself and his past basically.
So he's explaining how he is born out
of the past but is not imitative and is
not, can't be a merely
reducible to that past. Okay.
Um, I can read a little
bit of this. It's, um,
it's a bit scholastic I suppose,
but that's okay. Um, now
I can read it all if you want.
It may explain it better for you.
He says at lines 40
Anthony at 38 I believe,
37 38 perfect blood,
which has never drunk by the thirsty veins
and his left like food that remove is
from the table,
takes in the takes in the
heart in informing power
for all the bottling members
like that,
which takes its course through the
veins to become these further digested.
It does since where silence is,
is fitter than speech and then drops
afterwards on another's blood in the
natural vessel.
They're the one mingles with the other
and the one fitted to be the passive and
the other on the account of the
perfect place from which it springs.
That is the [inaudible] active and this,
so United begins to operate first.
Coagulating then quickening that tube,
which forest material it has been,
it has given consistency here. I think
it gets a little bit more interesting.
He says, the active force having
become a soul, like a plants,
but so far different than it is on the
way and the other already on the shore
then operates to the point that it
moves in, feels like a sea fungus.
And from that goes onto produce Oregon's
for the faculties of which it is the
seed.
Now my son
develops and spreads the force that is
from the heart of the beginner within her
nature makes provision
for all the members.
But how from animal it becomes
a child that they'll see us.
Not yet. I'm going to skip a little
bit more to the top of the next page.
Open I breast to the truth that
follows and know that as soon as the
articulation of the brain
is perfected in the embryo,
the first mover turns to it rejoicing
over such handiwork of nature and breathes
it into it.
A new spirit.
He breathes into it just like the
inspiration that Dante claim for his own
poetry before. Um, it's
spirit full of power,
which draws into its own substance,
that which it finds active there and
it becomes a single soul that lives and
feels and is itself revolves upon itself.
So what I think is,
is going on here is that
[inaudible]
ostensibly,
basically,
mmm
Stacy has describes the creation of the
body or the biological creation of a
body which comes from the
mingling of bloods, right?
MMM [inaudible]
and then after that,
how the animal that is created
basically is given a soul,
by God becomes a rational. It becomes
a human being. And the human being,
the human here is described, he
said, just translates it as a child.
But the word that's actually used as a
fun thing now fanta would be basically
just derived from the Greek
word for speech. So fun.
There would be a PR one who speaks.
So how an animal becomes one who speaks.
So humanity is,
is defined in a sense by the fact that
we can speak and reason basically.
Okay. Okay. Um,
and what happens here I suppose is
that even though the father is the j,
it generates the, um, the body,
the soul is directly
created by God. Okay. That,
so that there's two kinds of
individualities I suppose.
You have the body and the
soul and the soul is a,
is a uniqueness that is directly created,
inspired by God.
So if we consider this poetically,
even though Dante may have
been influenced, right,
in a sense created by the poets that
came before him and the less he has some
kind of direct inspiration that separates
him from the poets that came before
him, at least that's how I understand it.
Okay. And they, I think it's connected.
I'd done it points out the connections,
especially by the word speed
or he uses the word speed,
our inspiration twice right there,
they admit they imitate each other,
they parallel each other. Okay. And
the connection between fun thing, this,
the child who speaks is a direct
connection to language. Okay.
The language of poetry. All
right. All right. So that's,
I think
it explains rec retrospectively,
what Dante is claiming in Condo 24.
Okay.
About his poetic inspiration.
There's difference between
his own poetry and that of
that of his predecessors.
Now Canto 26 and can pass on to come 26
he passes in to the terrorists
of the last full. All right.
And here he meets his own self.
He's on the stage to poetic father.
Um, we don't, we need suddenly,
and he has his father wrecking.
He recognizes his father and his,
he is a debt to his father and at the
same time he was recognized as a brother
by his father. Okay. So his,
his individuality as
opposed as recognized.
The recognition is staged
here. Okay. The mineral ratio,
they paternal relationship
becomes a fraternal one.
MMM.
So I guess what I'm trying to point out
with this, the biological embryology,
um, is that he can be seen as derivative
and different at the same time.
So he's the same and it's
distinguishable at the same time. Okay.
Now this condo is in sharp contrast to 24,
I think because Dante wanted to distance
himself from those pellets in 24 and
here he wants to show,
um,
and similarity.
He's trying to sit and assimilate himself
in a certain kind of poetry. That was,
uh, four, four,
which metaphysics epistemology and
theology where all central, okay.
So it's a philosophical kind
of love poetry. All right.
MMM.
And I think he also redeems
this love tradition,
which is in a certain sense was
condemned and in fed no five. Okay.
With Francesca.
So this courtly love that was,
that caused in a way,
I suppose at least that and
Francesca claimed cause her downfall,
um, in saying that the gala halt was, um,
was the book. Right. And in fact,
no five here, he redeems it and he,
he purges it ink. Is it okay. Um,
we can start off by reading
the Theresa that begins at line
94. Whenever he, whenever we'd up,
we need,
sadly identifies himself to the pilgrim,
says such as in the grief of lice circus,
the two sons became unseeing
their mother again, I became,
but with more restraint when
I heard speak his own name,
the father of me and the others,
my betters,
whoever have used the suite and graceful
rhymes of love and without hearing or
speech,
I went on a long way in thought gazing
at him and did not where the fire go near
him. Okay. So Dante [inaudible], he,
he loses his faculty of
speech here because he's,
he's an almost like a child
before his father. Okay.
So his behaviors or imitates
his relationship to,
um, to we need suddenly. Okay.
MMM.
All right. And I'll point out
here as well that the, one of the,
one of the main differences
I suppose is between the,
the two poets is symbolized by the
casting of a shadow on the fire,
right.
So his act,
that reality of his presence there
and his body is what's really,
it was with the physical aspect
that separates him from the others.
And it's stands in for the,
um,
the aspect of his poetry that separates
him from the rest of it that rest of
these poets as well.
Um, let's see, and
since we're talking about poetic
genealogies, it's interesting that
Dante is, um, he refers
to him as a father,
but then we need sadly responds
by saying, Oh, brother,
he there whom I point out to the,
was a better craftsman of
the mother tongue versus of
love and tales of romance.
He surpassed them all. Okay. So in these,
in these, what, 15, 20 lines?
Dante as a child before his father and
his den acquainted with his father by
being a brother.
So they're put on the same level and
they're assigned another father. Okay?
So the grandfather of the mall
becomes the father and his father,
I guess who's not named
is note Daniela. Okay. Um,
an important poet for Dante and remit,
remit, throw us in the stony rhymes,
which professor Metsul dimensioned.
Um, Dante imitated him,
irritated him in those, in
those runs, he was a poet,
famous for his difficulty in reading
and, and underneath, it's very,
very hard to understand. An example
of the thrombotic loose. Okay.
Um,
so
and in the same paragraph in
this and these same series of,
of tercets paragraph in the English,
again,
we had the differentiation of
um,
the kind of school I
suppose that Dante is, um,
associating himself with and
the other school which would,
she wants to differentiate,
differentiate himself because he says
like out of note is different from
the one from Limo Jay.
So he is different from we
Tony, we turn it on, right?
So who was named alongside when on
June and Jack and Woody Allen Teenie.
So he's separating himself from um,
and sort of aligning himself with a
different kind of poetry. All right. Um,
so let me gather my thoughts. He, um,
I,
so I suppose he reinforces the kind of
genealogy that he wants to create for
himself.
All right.
Now this genealogy to I guess has its own
consequences in the modern age because
the word, the words in Italian for
the better craftsman in New York.
Fabro where the words with which ts Elliot
dedicated the wasteland as her pound,
as you probably know.
All right.
So this conversation here
really becomes an emblem for
happy political relationships, I suppose,
which you can recognize your betters,
recognize your forefathers,
and at the same time come out with
something that you recognize as new. Okay.
All right.
Um,
and some scholars have pointed
out that we didn't really,
I don't think if we had concentrated
on in federal 24 and 25 where Dante
utilizes a number of metaphors
from avid in Lucan and he has this,
there's just, Topo is called the Tucky
at noon quick be silent now, Luke,
and be silent now. All of it, he says,
and he basically steals from their lines
without recognizing I'm okay saying
that he is surpassing them, but at
the same time as he surpassing them,
he's using their own poetry
to surpass them. Okay.
People have pointed out in these con d
of the feeds that Dante is participating
in the sin by stealing from orbit and
Lucan and that this kind of poetic
relationship, it was
a negative one, right?
That he's stealing the
identity of the other.
Well here we have a different kind of
understanding of I'd poetic identity,
right? We have one that, that
recognizes the paternity of the,
of the father,
while at the same time allows
the sun to come into his own.
And this is coming into his own,
um,
is I think pointed out by,
by Dante,
the poet.
Whenever you says then at line
between Lens, uh, one 30, one 40,
then perhaps to give place
to others who were near him.
He disappeared through the
fire as though the water, as,
as through the water, a fish goes
to the bottom. Okay. So here the,
the father moves out of his way
so that Dante can go on. Okay. Um,
and
I guess he can progress okay. That
he doesn't get in his way. Right.
Um,
so
if Dante recognizes these people,
these poets as his predecessors,
um,
how does he differentiate himself?
Like how in this content and does he
differentiate himself from them? Um,
I think we can look at it
through the Lens of contract 25.
Um, we're the paternal virtue. Um,
the cell or the generation
of the slow granted,
the paternal virtue,
it's place while simultaneously claiming
claimed a direct creation of the soul
by, um, the spy ration of the Holy Spirit.
I think Dante isn't poetic individuality,
um, rose out of the artifice,
the style that they concentrate on here,
this sweet deck deed mortar,
this sweet sayings of love that he
attributes to it we need to sell.
So it grows out of the stylistic artifice
that these two poets represent our
note and um,
and Guido to form something new,
a new kind of speech and new kind of
poetic speech that's imbibed with the
divine,
that's guided by theological
Gordon moral meaning.
Um,
and I think we can see this
and how the,
um,
how these pair of poets are our cleanse
and how they're represented in this come
to him. All right. For
example, we need, sadly,
when he first calls out to Dante,
before we know who he is,
before he's even identified himself,
I think it's around line 17
following,
um,
he's, he's uh, he says, oh, thou
that ghost behind the others,
not from tardiness,
but perhaps from reverence.
Answer me who burned with
thirst and with fire. Okay.
Now the line in an Italian
is and focal the door.
All right? Now this is a direct quotation
of we need Sally's on poetry. Okay.
I'm in a sign it which he says in
grand piano and Foco out of town. Okay.
So I'm in great pain
and fire. I burn. Okay.
So in Foco outta those
basically repeated verbatim.
So the love poet who's burning for his,
for his lady metaphorically,
and his sonnet is now burning literally,
and the penitentiary in the
like the penitent fire, um,
that's purging is sin. Okay. Um,
so I think this punishment shows how
the perspective of purgatory is really
modifying,
giving us her moral sense to the love
poetry that gradient sadly belong in this
school of led poetry. Think
when you say belong to, okay.
MMM.
Another thing that differentiates them,
like I said before,
with Dante shadow showing that he's
actually there and that they're
in his body in flash
points to something else.
And that is that
his lady is actually the beginning of it.
It started a chain of grace, right?
So that there is a connection to his,
not just a metaphysical connection or
epistemological connection and value to
his lady, but a theological value
as well. Okay. Since he's like,
he says at line 58, I go up hints,
no, uh, no, not to be longer.
Blind lady is above
who gains grace for me,
by which I bring my mortal
part through your world.
So what these poets couldn't recognize
in their own lifetime, Dante is able to,
because of his poetry,
this
bringing together that he does,
which is actually hit the newness in
the new sweet, new style, I think, um,
which isn't just a metaphysical,
but it's the illogical. Okay.
MMM.
Did it put it in another way
if for greening? Sadly are, no.
Danielle, we don't have on candy who's
not mentioned here. All right. Um, again,
um,
if for these poets,
the lady was a philosophical or
intellectual phantasm, I suppose,
um,
we're Dante,
she's a real woman who enacted
a real change in his life.
Okay.
Who did that?
And that caused a chain of grace to
descend into his own personal story.
And his poetry, I think seems seeks to
close the gap between the metaphysical,
theological reality of God
and the historical contingent
of history and Dante,
his own personal story and that history.
Okay.
So love poetry for Dante takes on
an entirely new meaning here. Okay.
And I think we need to at least shows
that he understands this difference with a
perspective that purgatory gives him
towards the end of the contract when he
asks Dante to say a paternoster for him
to Christ whenever he enters heaven.
Okay. So it's really a coup, a
conversion, I think of, of love,
poetry, a purgation of the
worldliness of love poetry. Okay.
Um,
and finally I want to say we're going
to end a little bit early because I
actually have to run to another
building to teach right after this, um,
my own class. But I want to conclude
by saying a few words about our note.
All right. It's, it's
very peculiar that Don,
this is the only place I believe
in the divine comedy where, um,
and other modern romance
languages quote is that quoted.
Um, it's not Italian.
Basically. I could be mistaken,
but I'm pretty sure
it's the only place I'm
now out was, was famous, like
I said, for is obscurity.
The extreme difficulty of his ex,
his poetic expression and hear what
has done they do to him even though he,
he quotes him and the original right,
and he didn't really write these lines.
These lines are done things,
but what he does is he
makes this difficult hidden
poet come out in the open,
right to quote him.
Um,
he says so much, I don't
know. Note Seth so much.
Does your courteous question
please me that I neither can,
nor would conceal myself from you.
I am,
are not who weep and seeing as I go,
I see with grief past,
past follies and see rejoicing
the day I hope for before me.
Now I beg of you,
buy that goodness,
which guides you to the summit of the
stairway to take thought and do time for
my pain. And then he hit himself
in the fire. That refines it. Okay.
So there's a little bit of a,
Dante's playing here with,
with our notes on language,
if he was a difficult poet and
poet of love,
um,
besides Dante makes them really come
out into the open and say, what are you,
what are you saying? So, um,
and here also typical words
from the problem Saul, um,
traditions such as the value
and now the follower, Schwab,
um,
Cortez and shutdown,
they all take on different kinds
of meanings that before the,
the valor of value of the,
um,
of the love poet was not what it is here,
right?
It takes on a completely different
meaning in purgatory. Okay.
So he really stages in our notes on words,
the purification,
cleansing,
and bringing out into openness of
what loved poetry should really be,
where it should really lead you.
Okay.
Um,
and I guess to conclude,
mmm.
I want him to say that in the next condo
you'll see Dante submitting himself to
the same kind of purgation as these poets.
If these poets are cleansed by this
wallet, by this fire that refines them,
he ended up passing through a wall of
flame in order to get to where you can
enter into the, um, the, uh,
the terrestrial paradise. Um,
so that he's in reality cleansing
himself of the same kind of
issue I suppose.
All right.
MMM.
And I guess now I can
take a few questions if,
um, you have any, hopefully
it wasn't too disjointed the lecture,
but I'm happy to answer any
questions you might have or try to,
yeah.
And
to
bring critical eyes at
the patients that line.
I'm wondering sort of looking at later
to cancer and then you have the proper
relationship, I mean, station sort of
slowing,
turning started
going again.
I think you can reconcile them. I
mean, whenever Dante, whenever he,
he meets me and sadly he's silent, right?
He doesn't automatically make himself,
he doesn't move his father
out of the way stages.
And Dante both know if I'd done that,
Virgil is not going to be
able to go the whole way.
They know that he's only going to be able
to lead them a certain amount of the,
of the, of the trip, of the
journey of the journey. Right. So,
mmm.
So I guess I would interpret
it as an act of reverence,
just like Dante is silence
whenever he meets. Um,
whenever you give me squeezing sadly is
an act of reverence that he doesn't push
them out of the way he does it,
trample them. He's not in a hurry,
I suppose. So does that make, does
that make any sense? But I think it,
I think it's,
well you can interpret station says if
you want to see him interpret that as him
slowing his way on the way to God,
basically,
then you could interpret it as an act of
reverence to the person who allowed him
to actually be there and not
in limbo. Right. So that,
that's how I would, how I would
interpret it. I suppose, um,
that Dante in this and
26 is referenced to his,
to his father's at the same
time as he's showing him,
that he's showing how he's moving beyond
them by giving a theological meaning to
two. They're questionable.
Worldly love poetry.
So to answer your question,
hmm. When Dante talks about the
inspiration which you've identified as the
inspiration of the Holy Spirit,
is he making love synonymous
with the Holy Spirit?
And if so, um, don't,
looking back at the beach in new and when
he personifies love in the masculine,
um, I've always sort of
thought of in literature,
you read religious poetry and stuff, the
Holy Spirit's often sort of a feminized.
Now are those things,
um,
one in the same to him
love and the Holy Spirit,
I think there that
he's thinking of. Let's see. I think,
I think in that, at that point
he's thinking of love. Um,
I think Thomas and Saint Thomas
Aquinas mentions love as the purse,
like a procession of love as the movement
of the Holy Spirit within the trinity
between the father and the son.
So that both really
are within,
I participate in the same spirit.
So yes,
I think in that spot he is really talking
about love as the Holy Spirit as this
kind of inspiration or at least as,
as parallel to it.
It's ambiguous,
right?
He says he doesn't really say that
love is the Holy Spirit. Does he? He,
he's
purposefully ambiguous I think
because love poetry always has that,
the possibility of leading you astray
because it's an aesthetic practice, right?
It's, it's dolce, right. Sweet.
So I think that, that, that, uh,
um,
that yes is talking about love as the Holy
Spirit, you know, as this divine love.
But he's also talking about,
so I guess in reality that,
that there is a connection between,
you know,
the contingent historical world and
the metaphysical world of God. Um,
but then he leaves it ambiguous because
it can always be misinterpreted it and
the aesthetic can always lead you back
down to the terrestrial realm. Okay.
So does that, does that make sense? Okay.
Oh
Griffin.
Why do you think, or what do you think
is the significance of the fact that, uh,
the biological discussion
of guide reading this goal,
the fact that that's handled
by stages and that not,
they really highlight that by saying yes,
they just say if it's very good as well,
that he explained
that that one was
[inaudible]
not permitted to know God. It's a good
editor if they'll speak about the vinyl.
So I don't want to get
out of that, but, uh,
I just couldn't understand
why. Yeah. Species.
Okay. Well, I guess if, if,
if the question really had been about
what is the nature of the soul, right?
Like what, like what, what is Aristotle
saying? And the Dyneema about the,
maybe a virtual could
have told them about that.
But the actual question
is what does the nature,
how does the soul live in the afterlife?
And that is entirely Christian question.
That's based on a Christian theology.
So I think the fact that, um,
that Virgil defers to Stacey,
thus there is showing that is
connected with the fact that,
that the question is the actually about,
you know,
the afterlife and the afterlife is
specifically a Christian context.
That station is permitted to know and
not virtual. Right. Does that make sense?
Yeah.
Okay.
Capacity
technically. But I think the fact that
he asked her, they asked virtual first.
I don't know, maybe he's, he's saying
that that's, it's actually in Aristotle,
you know, this idea of the
immortality of the soul when,
after that it's actually there and,
um, perhaps virtual could answer it,
but then Virgil differs to stations
because it's because it's a theological
question that he's not privy to.
Is that okay?
All right. Well, we're going
to end a little bit early.
I hope that's okay. Second,
go change gears here. Alright. Um,
thank you for your attention and
for putting up with me. All right.
Yeah.